hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my YouTube and Facebook
viewers cozy blankets who was asking how
can she start talking to business owners
and get them to know about her and buy
from her in bulk so thank you for the
question I think that the first thing is
you know the best way to build a
business is around paying customers so
you have to figure out how your product
can sell to business owners so why would
they buy what's the incentive is it to
put their logo on the blankets now how
are they going to use it are the gifts
and the best way to do that is just
start talking to business owners so you
want to go where they're hanging out if
there's events in your city go there
start talking to them hanging out get to
know their challenges for other
entrepreneurs that you may know you let
them know about what you do but it's not
a sales pitch I wouldn't go in selling
them I go in asking them about their
business and asking them for advice so
you can say no we have these great
blankets we're trying to figure out how
the entrepreneurs can use it we find out
that you know some people like the logo
some people use it as giveaways what do
you think and it's a good way to start a
relationship with people you know I know
you've been on my facebook page for I
didn't really even know too much about
what you do is your business so it's
great also to expose entrepreneurs so
who are talking to like me about your
business and how you can help other
entrepreneurs I didn't know that you
sold to entrepreneurs so it'd be great
to kind of get that introduction and
because you know we've known each other
a little bit through at least a Facebook
page so you want to let people know what
you do you want to ask you the feedback
in for their advice instead of going in
for a hardcore sales pitch hang out
where they are hanging out it could be
online through social media twitter
facebook youtube channels or could be
also events and I first really start
talking to people to get a sense of the
market really know how people could use
you and how you could stand out compared
to everybody else before you go into a
full-blown marketing campaign you have
to really first understand your target
market so I hope that helps for
everybody else is watching a video if
you have some
gestions I'd love to hear we have to
think in the comments below or we have
another question please leave a comment
and if you like the video please give it
a thumbs up I always appreciate those
coming in it makes me want to make more
of these videos for you guys so thank
you and stay tuned for next episode
you